elon musk has to be one of the smartest
people alive right
i mean besides the fact that he's at the
forefront of an industry that will
drastically reduce carbon emissions for
as cheap as possible he also has other
companies that are straight out of a
sci-fi movie
a tech city ridiculous internet
connectivity speed powered by satellites
an interplanetary space-faring vessel
and my personal favorite chips in your
brain may musk
elon musk's mother said that she
realized that her son was a genius by
the tender age of three
and it seems that it's all in the genes
of the musk because elon's kids
seem to be turning out to be quite as
smart as their dad but where are my
manners welcome back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure to hit
the subscribe button and ring that bell
so you're notified
every time we upload a new video there
are conspiracy theories that elon musk
is just an alien trying to get back to
his people
and with the naming of his youngest
child musk has not helped to defuse
those rumors
x who was born on the 4th of may in 2020
is the sixth child of the tech
billionaire and canadian musician claire
boucher popularly known as
grimes x's five older brothers with
better human disguises are called xavier
griffin kai damien and saxon and were
all born to musk and his ex-wife justine
wilson via in vitro fertilization
xavier and griffin are twins born in
2004 while kai
damien and saxon are triplets born in
and elon musk had a secret school in
hawthorne california where his kids got
their education
yes that's right elon musk's kids do not
go to the regular schools that we all go
to
big surprise the idea for the school was
thought of by elon musk himself
his then five boys were removed from
their former schools because musk did
not feel they were being taught
what they needed to be taught now xavier
and his brothers attend this school for
gifted kids created by their father with
the help of joshua don
a teacher from their old school the
school is called the umbrella academy
sorry it's called ed astra which is
latin for to the stars
as if star base starship and star link
weren't already enough to fuel the alien
conspiracy theory but to be honest it's
not about a crazy alien dad trying to
get his kids back to their home planet
it's really about revolutionizing the
way education works for his kids
and eventually for everyone musk claims
that the current education system is
outdated and just works to download data
into kids brains
without them knowing why they need the
data as the first step as an example
he cites a screwdriver and a wrench
which would traditionally just be taught
to students to memorize their functions
musk says that a better approach would
be to put
say a vehicle in front of the kids and
ask them how they would disassemble it
this mental exercise eventually leads to
the conclusion of the need for something
like a screwdriver and a wrench
and the function of the tools are
understood easily so ad astra
is focused on developing the
problem-solving skills of the children
using the philosophy of first principles
and first principle is the method of
attacking a problem without any prior
assumptions
this is a method that musk himself uses
in his own life and a perfect example
is the 4280 tesla battery which is being
designed very differently from other
electric vehicle batteries
and the consequence is that the battery
will make cars faster have more range
charge less take up less factory space
produce less waste
water and cost way less as well but it's
not just
musk's kids at the school a few other
kids whose parents are spacex employees
are also in for the exclusive experience
and it's so exclusive that many parents
in california don't even know about the
school
however ad astra has since closed in
june of 2020 and elon musk has
introduced the online version called
astranova with joshua don as the
principal astronomer does not use the
age grading common in traditional school
systems
so the boys as well as other students
are simply just engaging their interests
and the exciting tasks they get and my
personal favorite
is the fact that there are no tests or
grades in the school
since the kids are really just thinking
of new ways to approach problems the aim
according to elon musk is to exceed
traditional school metrics on all
relevant subject matter
through unique project-based learning
experiences subject matter like
artificial intelligence
machine ethics to robotics coding and
even real world environmental dilemmas
for example a popular example of these
dilemmas is the lake conundrum
it centers around a town with a large
lake that feeds at water there's also a
factory which of course pollutes the
lake and prompts the response of
scientists who say that the lake will
die within a decade at the current rate
of pollution
however an affluent person who gains
from the factory bribes a popular group
of the science community to say in a
study that the lake has never been
healthier
the media then reports on the study
despite opposing views and politicians
decide not to do anything about the
factory the voters who also work at the
factory vote on the factory staying and
in the predicted 10 years
the lake dies the exercise requires the
kids to provide who they think is to
blame for the destruction however this
test is not aimed at getting the right
answer
but evaluating how the kids can
rationalize these kinds of dilemmas for
a school with kids as young as seven
i'm pretty intimidated since at that age
i solved tasks like balancing a light
switch between on and off to see what
would happen
and getting totally psyched by the sound
of me humming into a standing fan but
that's why they're the musks
in fact elon musk claims that when they
go on vacations
his kids always talk about returning to
school
but i guess it's not too late to join
astranova since tuition at 75
000 a year which when compared to
regular schools
is a steal and mr musk does value the
time he spends with his five oldest boys
since he has shared custody with his
ex-wife justine
after spending time with their mom in
the belair mansion they get to meet
their dad
youngest brother and stepmom musk has
called his boys the loves of his life
but what do you think
is elon musk really raising his kids to
be geniuses do you think astranova's
style is better than the traditional
school system
let us know in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video
make sure to give it a like and check
out more awesome ones on the simply tech
channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time